le cinéma maintenant avec un bien joli
film d'eric rohmer quatre aventures de
reinette et mirabelle 4 jolie fable sur
le thème de la fille des villes de la
fille des champs une idée née d'une
rencontre celle du réalisateur qui a
écrit filmé l'histoire avec l'une des
comédiennes qui lui a raconté sa propre
histoire
elle s'appelle le joël michael l air est
nette dans le film et nicole connu
langlois lui a demandé de lui raconter
sa première rencontre avec rohmer et ma
chance a été de raconter leurs bleus je
savais pas du tout qu'ils venaient de ça
le rayon vallée puis raconter leur bus
pour moi leur plus important c'est un
petit miracle faut absolument aller voir
ça puis m'a dit attends attends je
branche mon magnétophone et puis je
faire un film sur toi lors des pages
je n'ai pas cru et voilà comment leurs
bleus est devenue la première des quatre
aventures de reinette la fille des
champs et mirabel la fille des villes
avec chacune leur moral d'existence
quatre histoires de joël devenue une
fiction documentaire devant mr si tu
veux ça tient pas dans les vases
quelques astuces
non mais j'aime bien appris c'est bon
pour les chenaux joël et comédienne mais
aussi peintre
l'année prochaine je prépare les
beaux-arts scandé singer je sais quand
c'est fou mais je suis pas pourquoi ses
coûts alors j'ai l'impression qu'avec de
la technique ça m'aiderait pas là je
viens faire une concession pour l'école
non non non non et ce sont les oeuvres
originales de joël qui sont le prétexte
à des scènes savoureuses et quelques
millimètres de plus et c sont carrément
j'aime bien si tu trouves que c'est la
partie de la femme la plus jolie
c'est pour ça que jamais souvent au
centre pourront comme ça c'est bon rey
se réalise enfin ce que tu fais là
aux essais citerai sur wii a fait suis
étonné parce que d'un seul coup le film
ne sort et tout et tu sais pas j'ai plus
l'impression de faire du cinéma commence
l'imaginent dans les rêves d'enfants
aussi le cinéma
premièrement il y avait que cinq
personnes qui fait très peu il n'y a pas
toute une équipe de tournage très lourde
et tout et puis me disais bon allez
vas-y raconte moi tiens me tiens
raconteront à l'heure bleue ou van gogh
- tiens l'histoire d'identity soit du
chauffeur taxi plus je racontais et je
me suis aperçue de rien par contre ça a
été très facile mois après quand j'ai vu
le film je me suis dit j'avais tellement
l'impression d'être très nette
finalement je suis par élève c'est ça
c'est troublant l'heure bleue j'ai un
conte d'andersen et qui dit que les
fleurs la mise en balle et elle rentre à
l'heure bleue est alors moi j'allais à
leur plus pour voir les fleurs rentrée
des balles mais chut
un souhait que joël gare de sa poésie et
sa mère